j'étais jeune professeur et c'est pour
la première fois que j'ai été à paris
c'est pour ça que en plus c'est la
visite de gagarine à paris et au salon
du bourget de l'aéronautique
cette rencontre c'était quelque chose
d'inoubliable est tout à fait
extraordinaire
on ne s'attendait pas à s'approcher de
deux gardiennes puisque c'était une
légende une vraie légende pour nous une
icône si l'on peut dire c'est pour ça
que quand on l'a vu pour la première
fois nous les deux avec ma collègue on
était timide tout à fait timide et on
n'avait pas l'impression d'être à côté
de lui
c'est pour ça qu'on était on est restés
bouche bée
sans dire un mot on rougit toutes les
deux et l'huile il serait toujours et il
est vu nos émotions et seriez nous
saluer et la parole à d'autres à
d'autres personnes qui étaient un côté
mais on ne pouvait rien dire
alors on était ébloui tout à fait
où il était adoré il était aimé tout le
monde le connaissait il était habillé en
civil
on le reconnaissait partout et en ville
et à la lèvre drôme elle est toujours
entouré de gens de personnes qui aient
souriez alors hop on pouvait pas rester
un côté de lui son sourire
ils souriaient et on lui répondait alors
c'est une personne qu'on peut pas
oublier parce que c'est quelqu'un de
remarquable elle vraiment l'humanité de
pierre lemonnier tait parce qu'il était
l'homme la personne qui appartenait à
l'humanité c'est pour ça qu'on l'a
cueilli par tous avec beaucoup d'amour
on l'aimé mais nous nous étions très
fiers parce que on crier dans la rue
avait il y avait beaucoup de pancartes
on disait nous nous sommes dans l'espace
l'espace est à nous annoncer quelque
chose et inoubliable
absolument alors je suis tout à fait
d'accord parce que il réunissait non
seulement notre pays parce que tout le
monde
on était heureux alors tout le pays de
toute la population
mais le monde entier aussi j pour nous
il a beaucoup fait pour l'autorité de
notre pays pour leur est nommé de lui on
se dit qu'il a fait beaucoup
je crois qu'il comprenait que c'était sa
mission dans le monde de porter le nom
de ce type qui était le premier et il
était digne de cette mission
c'était un choix magnifique quand on l'a
sélectionné qu'on l'a choisi parmi
d'autres alors si c'est un choix heureux